haha pick up chicks look like a giant
It's Made in China well so were you
hello everyone welcome to a weekend
edition and today I'm going to open up a
package now this was something that came
to me I've held on to this for a couple
weeks maybe a month maybe more yeah so
this a little bit of a story it's a
story so hold up the package so
everybody can see this is our package
that's the package okay so i got this
email let me show you the email look at
this email okay so first of all it says
from gift the gram your friend sent you
a gift it's kind of like a skinny like
oh I don't think I want to open this I
never said Jonathan blocks is a guy that
I met and if that wasn't there in like
the description but look at the name of
what skip the grain your friend sent you
a gift it looks like it's totally sketch
anyway so then you click any open it so
let me let me show the audience here
give the gram your friends sent you a
gift anyway so then I had to open this
thing and it said you haven't accepted
your gift to Graham all you know what
this was like the the this is a second
email I think you're not open it already
oh ok the first one I didn't open it to
the thought it was skin and then the
supplement you haven't accepted your
gift the Graham from Jonathan blocks it
will expire in four days to receive your
gift a grand please click accept my gift
so this time I open it up I had to fill
in my name and I just never really got
it so the story is Jonathan likes is uh
he's an entrepreneur I met him and his
partner they have their own business or
some mastermind groups wasn't quite the
right fit yet but give him some advice
to happen with their business and then
this may be this which is cool ok let's
open this thing up
okay ready dun-da-da-da do you know it
is no you know what it is everything I
do I do it big I'll sure the audience
first name is my new penis curious whoa
Oh paper okay oh its bottom of what
campaign and painted what what would
what swell the only bottles that look
great and do good thermos well
technology keeps drinks close the
thermos for 24 hours hot for 1200 money
proud to ease facilities it's pretty
cool I think you your swab walls made of
double wall insulated stainless steel to
keep beverages off 12 hours full time
for send the photo of your swell to
adventures at swell bottle com movie
poster lunch how about a video swell how
about a video this is pretty cool Thank
You Jonathan we're going to wind up his
website so you guys can check them out
check him out of him in his partner up
and then if you want you can check that
the other one give the gram calm gifted
haha swell.com all right that's it but
that's the weekend edition go okay oh
that's perfect okay that's it no that's
it you're done let's see how long the
[ __ ] in about half an hour no way
what do you think audience yes if you
think Nina should get a half an hour
shoulder massage I'm setting myself up
for for a lot of work leave a comment